i'm kurt devino speaking for steven
petit
madden nfl 21 is a tale of two games
really
it introduces the yard the best new man
in game mode in more than a decade
situating itself nicely alongside the
breezy and fun
superstar ko mode that arrived last year
but outside of these exciting inclusions
that are well suited for short sessions
madden nfl 21 feels
all too familiar even for an annual
sports sim
thomas the ten pole modes that require a
deep investment haven't received
meaningful updates
and the on-the-field gameplay doesn't do
much to move the series forward and is
hampered by surprising technical issues
ea sports has done well as of late with
recognizing that not every player wants
to sink a
dizzying number of hours into franchise
or ultimate team
with madden nfl 20 ea added superstar ko
a sudden death overtime mode where each
player gets
one possession it returns in madden nfl
21
largely unchanged retaining its
excellent high stakes matches with
madden nfl 21
ea has added a second casual mode that
is even better than superstar ko
the yard is easily the most over the top
mode to ever appear in madden
inspired by backyard football teams of
six compete on an 80 yard field
gaining three possessions each to try
and score
you can play against the computer team
up with one or two friends
or see how you stack up online against
other players
while it doesn't feature nfl blitz ask
hits you can get really imaginative with
stripped-down playbooks
you're allowed to throw unlimited
forward passes behind the line of
scrimmage
and many of the plays are set up to
encourage this adding to this mechanic
is the ability to snap
the ball to any of your teammates the
yard hinges on extravagant plays as it
requires you to move the ball 20 yards
for a first
down due to the limited number of
blockers there's a delay before the
defense can pass the line of scrimmage
after scoring a touchdown you can choose
to go for a one
two or three point conversions which
require you to score from different yard
lines
there's a risk reward element in play
here as you can lose by a decent margin
even if you score three touchdowns bonus
points are rewarded for passing the ball
multiple times on a scoring play
the basic setup and chaotic variables in
play create some of the most
thrilling men moments i've ever
experienced and games typically only
last around 20 minutes or less
it's both brief and delightful making it
the antithesis
of madden's long-running ultimate team
mode unfortunately madden nfl 21 begins
to show its blemishes
in the familiar modes franchise once
again
hasn't received any noticeable
improvements it still gives you the
opportunity to manage every aspect of
your team
over the course of many nfl seasons but
it's essentially the same loop that's
been in place
for the past few years giving little
reason to upgrade if you primarily play
franchise face the franchise rise to
fame the single player story mode is the
worst part of the package by far
this year's iteration of face the
franchise attempts to reintroduce
more narrative after last year's
lackluster face the franchise qb1
it doesn't work at all rise to fame is
set up as flashbacks
told to a reporter back at the high
school where your legendary journey
began
i was out with food poisoning i told
them not to order sushi on a monday
everyone knows that's the leftovers from
the weekend
of course there's a stereotypical brash
starting qb
named tommy who gives you a hard time
quickly it's revealed that the starter
has a health condition that he's been
hiding which
thrusts you into the limelight in the
second half of a game after playing a
few games in high school
you pick to play in one of 10 ncaa
programs
and your rival turn wide receiver joins
you it flashes forward to your junior
year when you're
told by the coach that you'll split up
as quarterback with your frenemy
yes he wants to play qb again
in the upcoming season the problem here
is that your play on the field really
doesn't matter at all
despite winning in blowout fashion in
the two collegiate games i
started all the cutscenes mention how
the team was struggling
even after winning the college football
playoffs semi-final and dominant fashion
i was benched in the first half of the
national title game for tommy
the story only gets more ridiculous from
there but quickly leads you to the nfl
where it starts to play out more in the
fashion
of the traditional franchise mode unless
you really want to guide a player with
your name to the hall of fame
rise to fame is not worth checking out
you're far better off jumping straight
into the normal franchise mode grown
inducing writing stiff animations and
disjointed story arc makes rise to fame
every bit as lackluster as last year
since there's more of it here
it's actually even more disenchanting
the card collecting ultimate team mode
doesn't fear any better than franchise
when it comes to new features
at this point ea has added so many
superfluous details that half the time
it feels like you're playing a tedious
management sim rather than a football
game it also doesn't help that
ultimate team remains steadfastly
committed to microtransactions
which puts players who don't feel like
spending money on digital cards
at a disadvantage while there's much to
do an ultimate team whether you play
solo against the cpu
or online nothing here moves ultimate
team in a positive direction
assembling and modifying your team is a
monotonous task that forces you to
examine a slew of different attributes
in addition to a player's overall rating
to compose the best team possible
it's certainly deep and filled with
customization but now more than ever
the dullness of it all is much more
apparent
despite its shortcomings and the most
prominent game modes
met in nfl 21 still offers better
on-the-field gameplay than in previous
years
most of the time he'll let this go deep
for born
the biggest change i noticed came with
run defense
last year the run game was far too
challenging to stop but this time cpu
defenders
smartly filled gaps more often while
engaged with offensive linemen
tackling in the open field also received
noticeable improvements including new
animations
and fewer unrealistic broken tackles
on the offensive side of the ball the
main improvement comes with your evasive
moves which can now be utilized
with the right stick making cuts in the
open field to evade defenders
feels more intuitive than before two new
moves a side hurdle and dead leg
add to the number of ways you can make
the defender miss
since hesitation running is big in
football it's nice to see the dead leg
added
directional hurdles let you jump left
and right rather than just
forward which comes in handy when you're
running along the sidelines
all told ball carrier moves are more
dynamic giving you new ways to catch
defenders
off guard
when man in nfl 21 is running without a
hitch the football gameplay is quite
good even if it's
only incrementally better than last year
sadly in its current state
madden nfl 21 has some real issues
especially in regard to kicking on more
than half of my kickoffs field goals and
punts
there was some fairly extreme lag with a
kicking meter which led to laughably
errant
kicks more than usual receivers simply
do not turn back to look at the ball at
all
even when it hits them directly in the
back of the head there are also bigger
picture issues with the overall
experience
sometimes the field didn't fully render
forcing me to quit and reload
other times the game got stuck in a
loading lube after finishing a contest
lagging animations aren't super common
but i encountered one or two
every few games while i assume these
issues will get patched with the planned
day one update
they add up to create an inconsistent
and sometimes frustrating experience
madden has reached a crossroads one side
of the road is freshly paved and
inspired thanks to the shenanigans
featured in the yard
while the other is beaten down and
filled with potholes
with far more technical issues than
normal and large chunks of recycled
content
madden nfl 21 feels more like an update
than a brand new game
you